Il faut surtout que le gouvernement agisse,
il faut surtout que le gouvernement arrête de commenter,
euh arrête de constater ce que, euh.
L'on sait depuis des années.
Il faut que le gouvernement, euh. Change de politique
vis-à-vis de nos agriculteurs
et les soutiennent, et les soutiennent,
pas seulement dans les discours,
pas seulement dans les mots.
Et il y a besoin d'action, il y a besoin de disposition.
Et au au-delà de l'agriculture, nos agriculteurs,
il y a besoin d'un soutien au monde rural.
La ruralité française est en train de souffrir,
elle est en train de disparaître,
elle est euh.
Aujourd'hui en souffrance parce qu'elle a été euh,
abandonnée.